astounded when I received the message on
LinkedIn which is a professional
networking site which I'm there to
connect with other lawyers on a
professional basis not to be objectified
on the basis of my physical appearance
now I chose to include that message
within a tweet on Twitter because I
wanted to know how many other women had
experienced sexism and professional
spaces in the workplace and online and I
think that the response that I have
received from this tweet really showed
the the fact that it struck a chord with
so many women and men who have
experienced sexism and they've come out
and shared their story and I want women
to go away and take the message but now
is time to call out sexes and when you
feel comfortable and safe to do so
and can you explain to us why you think
it's sexist what he said he described
your photograph as stunning yes and
prior to that he also mentioned that he
realized it'd be horrendously
politically incorrect there was an act
there was an acknowledgment as the wrong
before his hen went on to articulate
that wrong and what do you say to those
who have been that clearly many people
supportive of you on social media some
more critical some say that it was an
overreaction to name and shame him given
as they say it he was paying you a
compliment what do you say to them I say
that I have received a phenomenal
backlash as women and men do when they
call out sexism it's not uncommon in it
considering the ramifications on your
professional career when calling out
that sexism unfortunately is something
that women do have to consider and if
there's nothing more than a silencing
mechanism it's preventing them from
taking a stand against misogyny sexism
and calling a kind of behavior no woman
needs to accept that give us a sense in
a bit more detail can you of the kind of
response you've had you say you've had
support but tell us a little bit about
the the other side of the reaction that
you've had
I want to pray too much on the
negativity of this that I've I've had
comment really rather vulgar discussing
my his physical appearance in quite some
detail and in a very sexualized manner
which again serves in my views of
silence women my voice hasn't been hired
instead what has become the content of
the messaging is again my body and the
lawyer cancer mr. Carter silk has
apologized to you
has he not are you satisfied with that
apology now the reason that are not
satisfied the apology is that the
apology is for the offense that I have
taken so there is no acknowledgement
that the message that he said sent was
inappropriate or is sexist and he hasn't
taken responsibility for that action and
that is why I'm requesting apology for
that message and give us a sense more
broadly as I say some people saying this
was intended as a compliment when is it
appropriate and when isn't it
appropriate to pay a compliment like
that in your view certainly not
appropriate to discuss and physical
appearance on LinkedIn and on
professional networking site that belong
dating website its LinkedIn is not
tinder okay and people have tried to
draw a parallel between what has
happened in this case on LinkedIn and
asking somebody else through the
workplace
they're asking somebody out who you work
with and what I'd say is that they are
very different situation okay you have
one where you are seeking to make
connections based on your professional
skills and you don't know often the
person that you're connecting with that
is the purpose of that connection where
are in the workplace when you work with
a professional you have I would have
thought do balik's a rapport in a
relationship though that both feel
comfortable to take the relationship to
our next step and there are those today
who also have expressed some support for
the action of shaming what he did but
not necessarily naming him because they
say that there is a risk then that you
are in some way subject to a kind of mob
justice of social media do you see that
they might have a point there
what I'd say is that in this instance
this was from a legal professional
someone very senior and as lawyers we
have a responsibility to uphold the law
and uphold the legal principles of which
doesn't rise and that includes gender
equality and anti sex discrimination
okay and that is why I chose you what I
have done whilst I respect the rights of
privacy and I think that's incredibly
important principle and the solicitor in
this case was named because in my view
the public interest of exposing sexism
outlier outweighed any privacy in this
respect and if people do not challenge
this kind of sexist behavior so we know
repercussions for their actions and the
behavior won't change and neither will
our culture how great an issue do you
think sexism is in the legal profession
I think it's rampant and that's not my
view actually that is from a report
which was published by the Bar Council
of this year and it says that sexism is
rampant to the bar and this was after
interviews with fastest women barristers
who express the sexism misogyny that
they'd experienced and I think it's
incredibly prevalent and it's
unfortunate because the legal profession
is historically in a place which has not
been open to women it's excluded women
and we want to open that space up not
only to women but to other minorities
and by balancing women by discussing
their physical appearances preventing
them from feeling comfortable to work
within that male-dominated profession we
need a real kind of change in attitude
behavior and culture you say that there
are many young people who don't want to
speak out about certain behavior that
they think is inappropriate because they
worried about the impact it could
on their career are you worried about
your career and speaking out having an
impact on you yes I am I am worried
about that I think again it just shows
their concern which women have including
myself about calling out sexism because
the ramifications of that can be
significant for your career and that's
incredibly unfortunate when you have to
really think about calling out the
sexist myth the hand that feeds you